I'm a day I'm games video manager I'm
based in Tel Aviv and I work with Israel
in Turkish gaming companies and yeah I
camp and I win games because of that so
let's start with a question by raise of
hands who wants to make more money from
their games raise your hands yeah that
makes sense because you're here today
and the obvious follow-up question
should be how can you make more money
from your games
honey Malkovich and noble PI's own
economy said he will never be wanted to
send invested in stocks or bonds or cash
basically saying he will never put all
his eggs in one basket and when thinking
about it why mobile games should be any
different why we lying on one source of
revenue and not buy diversify revenue
streams an industry is set up in a very
unique way which usually game genres
determine the game on possession you
have so in hyper casual games usually
see ad monetization in RPG in strategy
games usually see IP monetization and
this isn't a bad thing but today I
wanted to take a step back and rethink
this assumption ask yourself does that
make sense to focus on one monetization
strategy in your games and what can
learn from other genres and what can you
learn from other developers so today I'm
gonna talk about why diversify
monetization strategies in mobile games
then I'm going to discuss different
trends on this topic and then we're
going to finish with gram gains on on
stage we're going to share with us the
journey of revenue diversification so
why diversify as Markowitz earn by
diversifying revenue streams you're
actually decreasing the risk you have in
games but more than that you have more
options to monetize your audience which
can create an uplift in revenue and now
the reason is based on a Google Play
data and it's actually the first time we
are showing that on stage so let's take
a look what you see in the graph in the
x-axis is the percentage of revenue
coming from top 5% of spenders in the
game what you see in the y-axis is the
reactivation rate of trend buyers or how
likely is the game to get back churn
buyers
a picture that's a good one and what we
found out in our data that we actually
have a correlation between the two
things so if you look at the bottom
right corner you see that games that re
concentrating on revenue from a top 5%
of spenders they have actually less
likely to get back to on buyers on the
other hand if you look at the top left
corner on the star sign you see that
games that are really good at getting
back to on buyers are less dependent on
the top 5% of spenders they have so what
that means is that try to get one dollar
from a larger audience is actually most
of them when trying to get $100 from a
high-value user so what trends do we see
around monetization diversification
subscriptions new order dad an IEP so
subscriptions quite new in mobile games
but to all the dads an iPod are not new
per se we see some interesting trends
with them and you're going to discuss
that later but let's start with
subscriptions so who is using
subscriptions in the games please raise
your hand okay yeah a few hands that
makes sense and subscription is not a
fun concept in gaming we seen that on PC
and console bits like actually quite a
new concept in mobile games and we see
more and more developers who are using
this strategy on top of the IEP they
have in the game in order to create the
premium experience for users an action
on Google Play we see a growing momentum
with more than 70% Union growth in
subscribers and games and developers
were using this strategy reporting
different benefits of doing so so mixing
for for example reported that
subscribers pay 20% more than they used
to and scorpy reported that subscribers
have much higher LTV and another reason
of using subscriptions is that can
actually help you diffuse the feeling of
regrets in-game so what happens
sometimes that users binge on IEP and
then if you regret doing so but if you
subscriptions you can actually change
that so instead of hitting all the
Halloween candies in one day user will
eat one candy
each day for a long period of time and
then they feel worse we're doing so so
how to design subscription experience so
that's something that will cause a
mindset shift you can use your IP excuse
repackage them and offer them is
Crypton bundles can actually work for
you but we think that you can do more
than that but what IP is more about
ownership of things you think to only
keep something the game subscriptions
mobile access to a premium experience
access users can gain and also lose and
you have too many use cases for
subscriptions in games
the first ones to convert new bars often
looking for really good deals so if you
take a look at the examples that's
copling on top of the IEP dealer
offering many exclusive rewards like
cross protection in the game and also
hide the daily caps and the offering
disbanded early early on in the game
just stuff after first time user
experience and the idea behind that is
they are trying to also make sure that
new bars would stay longer than the game
it playing longer sessions and second
with second use case for use cases for a
subscription is to create a loyalty
program for your most valuable users so
this is often looking for premium
experience rewards for the commitment
after the game and also prestige feeding
and in the example see that Rodya for
the VIP users often quite a lot extra
currency exclusive tournaments early
access to new content and access to a
special durable so that's quite a lot
so that was subscriptions and let's move
to avoid that so is it a new trend you
are overseeing ask yourself why I'm
speaking about to all that so it's not a
new monetization model we've seen that
for a couple of years now but what the
Google AdMob team found out recently in
research they did is that IP heavy the
purpose who didn't focus on ads before
I'm starting to rethink the monetization
strategy they have in games and as a
result they're implementing more and
more awarded ads and that's why we see
more hybrid games today in the industry
both IP any old ads implementing them so
I use the word that so we have couple of
reasons for that first of all you can
monetize you know you're not paying
users with involved ads you actually
give your users the option to choose the
currency they would like to pay with
time or money it can also increase your
engagement in the game of both pairs and
non pairs users are getting back from
frequent into the game and also play
longer sessions and third queries
of fusing awarded ads and you've may not
be familiar with that is that can
actually predict IP conversion in games
so what Kongregate found out recently in
their games is that new users who watch
an ad in a first-ever session during it
in the game actually much more likely to
make an in-app purchase and they saw an
offer for between 250 to 500 percent in
that conversion rate which is really
amazing so how to design and what did
that experience we know it can be a bit
shrieking so we're showing with you an
AdMob primer that can help you in the in
the process soon to think about
placement of the ads use a targeting
cadence and measurement and let's see
what congregate all doing for each one
of these points so first of all the ad
should be part of a game economy design
and should give something meaningful to
your users but the same time make sure
it doesn't compete directly with your IP
and every user should have access to the
ads but if you decide to remove this
access to paying users don't forget to
give them the rewards and more is not
always but always better they found out
that between 6 to 8 ads per user per day
is the best practice and lasting don't
forget to measure imported metrics like
ad viewership and frequency because you
can segment your users with that and
optimize the performance of each segment
ok so let's talk about I appear a little
bit so what we see with IP is very much
what we see with the world ads
increasing number of developers who
didn't focus on IP before really focus
on ads are starting to shift that focus
and that either implementing IP in
existing titles or started to develop
new IP based games for the first time
tabs games for example Brazilian company
renown for hyper casual games decided to
Double Down I pin in the bid wars titles
which is an auction like strategy games
really nice games and they've been
working well closer to the play team in
your time on that in less than two years
the Sun up of more than 20% in time
period so that was a game-changer for
the company and as a result IP today is
part of the company's
the G so I developers are looking to
diversify the IP so first of all
successful IP games can be mentioned and
develop a really small teams and simple
operation infrastructures in some cases
we're seeing teams of small stent people
who are responsible for multi-million
success stories IP games also rely less
on massive number of installs so instead
of focusing on game launches the
actually shift and focus to a more
long-term sustainable KPIs that game
engagement in IP games is also all about
taking back control of your own revenue
in self depending on other companies to
provide you this revenue and if you have
the right tools in place you have the
flexibility of testing and changing and
optimizing your game so for those of you
looking to diversify we die before the
first time we double down on that that's
a basic phone for you that can help in
this process so first of all in to think
about game economy designed very early
on in the development process because
it's part of a core gameplay loop so
don't forget that don't think how to
convert users to be paying users or how
to create a value for money perception
in your game and lastly in difficulty
retain your users and repeat the
purchase events basically shifting the
focus from and one even one-time event a
game launch to treat your game as a
service and Wescott don't want to miss
develop and publisher to share with us
some insight on this framework and the
reason we ask are the ones that have an
amazing story they're also known for
hyper casual games and they have a
leading title rodeo stampede how many of
you know where those stampedes pretty
non-game yeah okay and they decided to
Double Down I pinned it in that game in
ness in Estonian they managed to shift
the idea to IP ratio in the game so IP
today 60% of the revenue in only couple
of months ago it was 40% and they showed
us some insight it can help you also to
think about IP so first of all you need
to keep your design very simple first
because then you can add more layers and
change that quite easy later on but at
the same time try and montes as much
users as you can by using different
currencies so they're using an ad
currency in the game world and also an
IP currency that targets different type
of users and they found out
that we want to convert more users to be
paying users it's really valuable to
understand what is unique about each
segment and what excites them in the
game order staying and playing longer
session the game because then if they
can you can create targeted offerings
which makes sense for each segment and
last it's really important to invest in
more content either by deepening the
contact you already have so if you have
characters add more of them or by adding
more system and features to the game in
order to create a lifespan with many
events and promotions it's really
valuable to have a system that you can
customize because then you don't need to
invest so much time and effort in each
event in each promotion you can do much
more with much less okay so we discuss
very briefly subscriptions rewarded adds
an IEP and I gave you a small glimpse
into new opportunities hopefully it will
have meaningful discussion with your
team about monetization as field team is
the current status quo you have in your
company your best strategy and now I
want to welcome on stage Aaron who is
going to show you this really amazing
journey of DRAM games around revenue
diversification
so please welcome in on stage yeah
[Applause]
so let me just introduce you before we
start so I ran into the chief revenue
officer of Graham games he joined the
company two years ago before that he was
a senior manager at McKinsey and it
Graham games he is leading the
production monetization of the company
and he also led the transformation of
the company from an ad revenue based
company to a majority IP revenue based
company so we thanks for joining the
talk thank you really appreciate that so
let's dive into the first question can
you tell us a little bit about Graham
games what kind of games do you have so
Graham games was primarily founded as a
company that makes quick games make them
fast iterate fast fail fast and then
launch them to the market separately
with lean teams
that's why initially they focused on ad
based games like hyper casual games I
think so far we have about nine games in
our portfolio and eight of them are
fully close to fully ad funded and hyper
casual to casual games the most famous
ones being ten ten and six building on
that we have recently last year launched
emerge dragons which is right now 95
percent IEP base so we have shifted even
though using the core loops and
mechanics that exists in hyper casual
games we have actually successfully
transitioned into a more IIP majority
revenue source so right now we're
probably more than 60% IEP revenues as a
studio and 30 to 40% ad revenues so
we've been working together for a couple
of months now and we had different
discussions on that decision to
diversify with IP so can you share with
the crowd a little bit why did you know
what was reasons behind the decisions
and when it happened sure II think so as
businesses
I mean in my view it's very useful if
you're one of the two like you're either
a small company small studio with people
that focus on quick game like smaller
games launching them fast like the
initial stage that we used to be or if
you are a publisher that can really turn
out really produce games really fast
like once one game a week or something
and you can do rely on publishing other
studios to help you but if you're
somewhere in the middle probably
focusing on one game or a few games and
focusing on a more stable revenue source
that is not affected seasonally or that
does not rely on other intermediaries
between yourselves and players because
ad revenues are not you can't really
control what ads people see you can't
really control the volatility on the ad
revenues so you can only manage it by
increasing your number of games as the
business grows so that was the core
reason why we wanted to switch and we
have reused unmerged mechanic that we
developed in our other games like merged
and merge town and we used it and merged
dragons it was the core of the game but
we've used it we merged it with a camp
so that people actually have items that
they merged up and items that they
actually wanted to keep so this is then
turned into a higher retention higher
engagement higher our pool game
eventually and when did it happen the
decision so this was around early last
year this was around actually end of
probably so at that point we had three
hyper casual games and we had realized
that every new game actually boosted
your revenue but the exponential growth
was not there it was almost more linear
so what happened was we said to go to
the next stage - we need to have a game
on top grossing charge we need to have a
game that has stable number of DEA you
people that you acquire stick with you
it's not like the leaky bucket example
like people actually go air and then
they leave
if we wanted the more longer-term
engagement with them and then we have
decided to open up a studio in London
actually so I up until that time we were
in Istanbul and we set up the company
and hired everybody we had at that point
there but to do the switch into IEP you
also need people who have done this
before and with people with more
expertise more experience and then
London overall is a city that's very
attractive that you can actually have
these people join you join the team and
then work on this game so that's what we
did and launched merge dragons from a
London office from our London studio and
we launched it on in June of last year
so from that um constantly iterated the
game added new features even today I
think the LTV is probably three times
what it used to be when we first
launched it so other than opening an
office in northern what know what what
the next steps following that decision
what you didn't need to change the
company what you need to know start from
scratch I mean at that point so we knew
what we were good at and we knew what we
required to also improve on our side
like we were people with Graham games
like with the exception of me is a very
developer oriented management base so I
think we were very good and I going to
the cold let's you know work on this for
two nights and get it out of the way
let's just like for Red Bulls and then
do this type of a mindset right but I
think we did not know like have the
ideas about like the business management
the layers and the typical performance
management so up until that point we
said let's keep the culture we built
let's keep the good things about having
a startup mindset and it's the type of
people that when something stops working
they always like open it up and see like
what's wrong like tinkering like always
going into the details so we tried to
get people who share this vision share
this mindset but with people who also
have done this preview
see with the IEP game so that not to
reinvent the wheel so to speak so that's
what we tried to bring in and we also
brought maybe about ten people from our
Istanbul Studio to London and then hired
around 20 more people directly to our
London office but these people our
people have worked on level designs
people who have worked on character
designs for an IEP game these things
really matter like and hyper casual I
think the core thing is like to give
enough feedback to the players or is it
really enough differentiation but you
don't really focus on when you level up
the character gets very different or you
don't really focus on a longer-term
engagement what you focus on your
retention metrics like d1 d7 so we hired
people with this expertise and combine
them while trying to maintain our
company culture and seemed to work well
I guess and what is you know can you
show it a bit more about what exactly is
different in developing an ip-based game
compared to an ad based game what kind
of metrics do you look at when you do
that I think it almost feels like to us
like a ap game feels closer to making a
movie than like almost making an
application or game I mean it's a very
extreme example but we made 10 10 and
actually 10 hours so it was a hyper
casual game but we I think it literally
took like at Thursday morning an idea
and by Thursday evening the game was
ready we put it on the market we saw
good numbers and then we launched the
game but I he is a different story
because you don't really make you don't
really make your money a based on your
averages you make money based on your
tail what that means is on an hyper
casual game you actually see d1 Ritesh
and d7 Ritesh and what's our average
revenue per user per day whereas in an
IEP game at the end of the day you focus
on the top 5% of your most engaged
players so your average player is not
directly correlated with your average
revenues you actually care about your
top
% top 10% of your engage place how was
their experience so comments mattered
more ratings mattered more communities
matter more all of these things like one
rating or one review you read somewhere
could have really extensive implications
for you so that's why you need to be
very much more I think almost iterative
in hyper casual game it's almost it's
almost like trading you know like you
you acquire users you they play the game
for a few days they leave and then you
watch that whereas it a high a P game
with a higher long-term retention it
becomes like overall experience almost
like how is this person now on their day
thirty five what type of dragons they
see what type of items they interact
with we always have like our junior mid
high level player where they're up in
their experience how much more time are
they expected to spend what is their
level of engagement how's that varying
so those things are very different what
we tried to bring them in from our past
experience with hyper casual games is
it's very hard to launch an IEP game
fast and we're not still perfect at it
but what you can do is you could take
certain loops or certain mechanics that
you know that work put them out first
and in d1 d7 see how they do except like
more intermediary expectations KPIs on
what you think you should have and only
then act on it that that for us is the
similarity but the core differences is
more about engagement rather than
averages okay in retrospect other than
the acquisition by Zynga were you happy
with what happened for the launch of
much dragons we were we were very happy
and I think even internally that's you
you share things at a different level
with your players when it's more like
when it's a more immersive game because
when I don't know how many people here
played ten ten or six but those are the
games that you don't feel those are
again like you never like a crazy 10/10
fan-like it's the type of game you would
play that wouldn't really intimidate you
you would play it for a few minutes in a
day and then put your phone down
but in merge Dragons you see you really
see people who are fans of that game
even more than you are like as the
person like who who made the game right
people you see people who draw like some
mad dragon requests who's like I have
ideas who spent the many hours on a date
on that game those things really I think
emotional fulfillment is much higher in
that sense the teams that work on it the
ownership they feel is also much higher
like I think I'm hyper casual is more
almost about like you make a game try it
ship it and it's almost like you have no
personal connection whatsoever because
there's a high chance that that game
will not be launched whereas in an IP
game it's about the feature you're
adding what about we add this chest here
what happens if we add the ship here and
that brings goodies you know to our
players it's much more of a deeper
discussion and it's a live product at
the end of the day yeah okay so we need
to close that part of the session it was
really interesting so thank you Iran for
showing that with the audience and just
to conclude this the session which is a
little bit about versifying revenue
streams and if you have any questions
and any help with that feel free to
reach out to Google playing team members
and we'll be happy to help you with that
and you have some times for question now
so we are open for questions if there
are any yeah over there you have a mic
no just a second the mic is on the way
I thanks for the talk my question is do
you believe that the combination of
in-app purchases and in-app
advertisement is beneficial at all times
because what you can see in top grossing
games strategy games like over 70% rely
totally on in-app purchases only they
don't have you know advertisement so why
do you think they're doing it and if you
believe that perhaps this you know
in-app advertising would break their
in-app purchases ecosystem yeah so a
very good question I mean we up until
August we did not have any ads on merge
Dragons so it was fully IEP based in
August we've added the rewarded option
the ads revenues there's a there's a bit
of I'd say almost a lack of transparency
on the way today you get your as
revenues per player basis like you can't
see how much revenue you get for one of
your players so it's very hard to
actually allocate your ad revenues into
players and then compare like if it
leads to any cannibalization or not
because this person watches that so
that's why you go with manual filters
you either filter the number of videos
they see or the number of players that
are able to watch the videos if they
make a payment they take them out or the
rewarded video what we did was we kept a
number of videos that people can watch
and only kept it I think at to four
players that's why for us and we could
see the revenues and it actually added
like an incremental benefit to the time
where we had videos to the time we did
not have versus the time where we had
and I think it's a choice really like it
depends also how you monetize your
player base like where you want to give
that rewarded option to your players to
us it's been beneficial so far one more
question if we have any one more no
questions
okay yep oh yeah thank you
first what is the split in your audience
between women and men in murders
arrogance and the second how you if it
possible
exactly track the numbers of revenue
from IAB and it's when you're changing
something so things thank you the the
men versus women split like we don't
collect extensive information from our
players but based on I think where we
see with people who log on using social
media we think it's around 65 percent
female
it's and we don't do anything specific
about this like I think based on our
current marketing and currently
optimized what we think is optimized
marketing that this is the audience that
we ended up with so it's accused female
and the second question was I think how
do we choose how we split like how do we
see as versus IPs how do you see the
impact of change in the game yeah yeah
so it's when we generally add the new
feature we leave around like a month or
long longer testing periods it's harder
to do they beat estimates because ads
again like many things change and it's
I'd like what we're lucky with is that
we have eight other ad based games so we
can also compare the ad revenue to CPMs
between those games and this game like
is it really change when we change
something what does the ad revenue here
grow more than the others I appeals
generally easier to see like at a per
player where they're at in the game you
could see like if it's something
increases or decreases you can track it
more effectively but ads you have to
group that's a core problem okay thanks
everyone
thanks Aaron thank you hope it was
interesting for you guys
and that's it for that session I do